okay so in this quick video we're going
to discuss the difference between
introns and exons so let's get started
okay so when we go through this process
we need to understand a few definitions
and first of all the definition of a
gene from this picture you can see a
gene is a section of DNA with
information to construct a protein let's
take a little closer look at this
picture a little zoom in and we can see
that a gene is actually made from a
variety of these introns and exons and
that's the whole purpose of this video
to show and to understand the difference
between the two but introns and exons
are the DNA that make up genes so here
is a gene right here here's a section of
DNA notice how a pairs to T and C pairs
to G so now I've color-coded everything
in red will eventually be deemed an
intern and everything in blue will
eventually be deemed an exon well the
other definition I want to bring up is
the definition of transcription the
process of using a DNA template to
create a strand of RNA and in this case
we're going to create messenger RNA so
the process of transcription is going to
begin when an enzyme called RNA
polymerase attaches to the double helix
of the DNA and actually breaks the
hydrogen bonds between the a's and t's
and c's and g's so i'm the exposed DNA
is where we're going to watch
transcription occur you might know if
there is a DNA g then through
transcription a c is going to be matched
if there's a DNA t and then a will be
matched if there's a DNA a then a u will
be matched there's a DNA C and then the
G will be matched and so one by one
nucleotides are delivered to this RNA
polymerase and a chain of RNA begins to
grow the enzyme RNA polymerase moves on
down and prise open even more a's t's
c's and g's now what about the DNA at
the back end the DNA the back end kind
of resist and transcription will now
proceed with the exposed DNA letter
so now we have a long chain of RNA being
created so the enzyme RNA polymerase
moves on down the DNA reuse it's the RNA
polymerase prize open the next group of
a's t CS and G's and transcription
proceeds notice how transcription is
actually building off of introns and
exons both introns and exons are
transcribed and that's fairly important
so the enzyme RNA polymerase continues
to move on down and transcription
proceeds and as we are nearing the end
of this transcription process again we
have a growing chain of RNA and in this
case we're building messenger RNA but
notice how the growing chain of RNA is
actually a combination of information
instructions in red and glue of introns
and exons now we're going to ignore
we're going to move the DNA away and now
we're going to focus our attention on
the RNA that's been created now that's
not final messenger RNA this is what is
called pre op pre mRNA because of the
red introns and the blue exons we have
to process this RNA this pre mRNA before
it is reached the final mRNA and so now
we're getting into what introns are
interns are sections of RNA that do not
code for a protein
therefore exons are the sections of RNA
which will will code for a protein these
are sections of RNA that will become
expressed and translated into a protein
introns in red are eventually going to
be removed from that strand of pre mRNA
and the blue exons are going to be
spliced together into one long chain and
when this process is finished we're
going to just call that chain mature
mRNA the red introns that are removed
are eventually just broken down and the
nucleotides are recycled for use later
in the cell okay so now we're going to
process this pre-mrna and it begins by
removing the introns in red there are
proteins that come along and remove
these introns in red and now the ones in
the middle of the RNA kind of fold and
eventually are spliced out and notice
what happened is the blue exons were all
joined together into a long chain this
is the mature mRNA and now that the
mature mRNA has been created the mature
mRNA will move to a ribosome world v
where the information the instructions
will be translated into a protein so
here's a ribosome and here comes being
mature mRNA that was just created and
now the process of translation will
occur at a ribosome the process of
making a protein and so Aug you might
know is a codon it starts this process
and tRNA delivers an amino acid called
miss I mean the ribosome moves down to
the next codon GCU is the codon for the
delivery of alanine ribosome moves down
to the next codon uuu is the codon for
the delivery of sino alanine and one by
one the ribosome reads codons and
transfer RNA delivers amino acids well
now we get to this codon UGA and that's
a stop codon and that stops this process
of translation the ribosome actually
breaks apart and that mature mRNA is
eventually broken down and degraded and
can all be recycled and so now we have a
protein that's been created but this
protein if you recall was only created
from the instructions of exons the red
introns were spliced out and had no
functional purpose in the creation of
this particular protein right here and
so there you have the difference between
introns and exons I hope you found this
video helpful thanks for watching